ever since the Walt Disney Company
announced its plans to acquire the
majority of studio 20th Century Fox's
assets in a 71 point three billion
dollar merger set to be complete in 2019
one question that has been on every
superhero fans mind is whether or not
Marvel Studios would recast members of
the x-men after all Disney's purchase of
Fox does include the entire slate of
mutants who will soon join the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and just about know
x-man is more beloved than Wolverine
because I'm the best series of what I do
curiosity about such a recasting turn to
foaming at the mouth excitement when
longtime x-men film franchise producer
Lauren Shuler Donner told slash film in
February 2019 that Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige would start
scouting for a younger actor to play the
next Wolverine as soon as the Disney Fox
merger goes through from there the
internet kicked into overdrive imagining
who that younger actor might be and as
odd as it sounds a first social-media
frequences are and ironically loving the
idea of Harry Potter series starred
Daniel Radcliffe stepping up to portray
the new Wolverine assuming the role that
Australian actor Hugh Jackman played
from 2000 until 2017 piggybacking a
fully online chatter digital artist boss
logic created stunning artwork imagining
what Radcliffe could look like as a
hard-bitten nearly indestructible hero
though there's really no predicting
which actor Feige and the Marvel team
will end up tapping and no one involved
either Marvel or Fox has commented on
the plausibility of Radcliffe taking the
role the entire situation actually
started as a joke the idea gained
popularity after Radcliffe participated
in a wired autocomplete interview after
answering a few Harry potter-themed
questions Radcliffe tackled the subject
of whether he is in fact the new
Wolverine there's gonna be a new
Wolverine movie in which it starts off
with Hugh Jackman being put into a hot
wash and then when he comes out it's me
so yes Radcliffe joking tone made his
answer seem like total fast but comic
book fans were quick to ponder whether
the Harry Potter alum could actually be
telling the truth and surprisingly a lot
of people were down for it with a vast
majority of Twitter users arguing that
Radcliffe would simply need to bulk up
before formally joining the x-men movie
world one fan wrote in response that
could work give him a year of pro
Dean shakes growth-hormone steak
creatine testosterone injections check
in rice trained by the mountain in
Iceland and also a loss of crumpets yeah
that would work it's doable that would
be awesome another added that if British
actor Tom Hollands can play the American
superhero spider-man there's nothing
stopping England born Radcliffe on
portraying Wolverine a few fans who live
and die by comic book accuracy even
noted that Radcliffe might be better
suited than Jackman ever was in one
regard Wolverine is 5 foot 3 while
Radcliffe is 5 foot six and Jackman is a
staggering six foot two sadly though
what began into joke remains just that
Radcliffe has since come forward to
clarify his statements and make it
crystal clear that he isn't playing
Wolverine no confirmation from Disney or
Fox needed speaking to IGN for a recent
interview discussing his new project the
TBS show miracle-workers Radcliffe
shared this is what happens when you
make jokes and made a joke about playing
Wolverine and the internet seems to
think that I was putting that out there
on my dream board cosmic ordering system
so there you have a Radcliffe won't
become the man behind the mutant but hey
if the internet didn't hate the thought
of pint-sized to Radcliffe rising to
serve us an ex Wolverine it seems people
may be open to hearing other outside the
box ideas so long as the actor doesn't
mind chugging protein shakes and working
out eleven teen hours a day check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]